never but you never cook again back
please always push it over to the brain
free never expect your respect I really
fifties you'll be fine
[Music]
the Dark Knight Returns was a tour de
force a PS did easy stunts and other
French terms that make something sound
really good upon its release in 1986 it
changed the landscape of comment in an
instant make in the 1966 version of
Batman completely redundant and
presenting a darker version of the Caped
Crusader that would mould the next 30
years in comics to come it was a huge
success both critically and commercially
and as with all successful things the
manner that taught me once more give
more I want more this little curve it's
crap so in 2001 Frank Miller was
commissioned to write The Dark Knight
strikes again it's a sequel that takes
place after the initial continuity of
the original book often works like this
suffer from a sophomore curse when a
property's so highly regarded it makes
it difficult for its sequels and
follow-ups to be as good as the original
do you a sentimentality nostalgia you
know general people just thinking stuffs
really good and they don't want to see
it ruined
we've seen it with Terminator Star Wars
lore of the Rings the list just goes on
and several hot properties are forced to
have a bling every sequels down the line
The Dark Knight strikes again was no
different criticized by many the
reputation of this boot precedes they're
often used as a punchline and laughed up
by many it still is regarded by some
like Grant Morrison as groundbreaking
I'm here to find out if it's as bad as
everyone says or if it's really good
so with that out the way let's dive into
the Dark Knight strikes again upon
opening the book you were immediately
hit with how bad the art is in
comparison to its predecessor well there
was never a fan of the Dark Knight
Returns art style this makes it look
like a DaVinci painting most of the
pages here looked like they were drawn
by Stevie Wonder most of the panels are
missing backgrounds the women looked
like Nicki Minaj and it has just a
splash of the lazy a bird Frank Miller
that so many would come to hate you
could use these pages as toilet paper
and it would still be more productive
than what Miller put out the first time
I read this book I remember getting to
the admin section and just flinging it
out of my hand I was a moody teenager I
hadn't lost my virginity so I had a lot
of pent-up anger until that happened
when I was 28 a teen I was 18 when that
happened and she was a model and she
paid me anyway the point is this book
was really garish garish and it was a
chore to read I'm how do you say that
with age it's become slightly more
bearable but you have to really force
yourself through the pages and I can
imagine this massively putting off new
readers opening on three different new
segments all happening at once the booth
feels like a complete mess Frank Miller
needs to listen to focus by Ariana
Grande
because it's lacking focus yeah a lot of
these jokes they don't work well I can
get from the gobble is that America is
in a state of martial law yet then you
spin it so that it's a positive thing
crime is down but so is free speech the
heroes of the world are gone this really
reminded me of the weapons of mass
destruction scandal that happened after
9/11 the population believed it was
right to go to war with Iraq because the
media reported every single prejudice as
a [ __ ] and we all know how that turned
out
so this is a really relevant satire that
unfortunately due to its presentations
loses impact in between each news report
is a post of news in the new and once
there's maybe a hint that people only
watch the news for entertainment now it
could have been presented in a better
way the focus of this opening issue
revolves around getting the heroes back
the atom has been trapped in a petri
dish green lanten is flown off earth and
the flash is forever running on a
hamster wheel to give electricity to the
world leading the sons of Batman Carrie
Kelly now cap girl
chod is an onslaught to get the captured
Crusaders back and had the art being
slightly better these moments could have
been much more exciting
there is three pages of the book that I
just Microsoft Word backgrounds and in
its entirety it feels sloppy we see a
Batman soldier get crucified for using
one of his guns to kill an enemy but it
makes you wonder like why were they
giving guns in the first place if
they're not allowed to use them the book
is contradictory to its own ideas and
it's a shame that it doesn't allow the
characters to carry over the
intelligence that they possessed last
time one of the main criticisms I've
seen against this book is that the
public don't seem to care that the
president is a hologram controlled by
Lex Luthor in the past I would have
agreed with the critique however after
seeing how politics have evolved within
media I kind of side with Frank Miller
on this living in the UK I've seen
Teresa May promised tough negotiations
of brexit say she will step down if not
elected by a majority lambaste the DUP
and then still side with them in order
to stay in power and honestly you seem
to care the older generations seem to be
used to politicians lying and are now so
apathetic to it they ignore any story
that should be met with anger towards
the government Donald Trump slams
Mexicans transsexuals and gay rights
yes speechless when discussing neo-nazis
and his supporters don't seem to care in
fact they rally even harder for him
originally one of the lowest points the
presidential hologram is a satirical
look at how useless the people of the
Western world have become in the past
there would have been revolution yet now
we are happy to sit on our phones
reading stupid Batman reviews when the
world could be changed please don't
unsubscribe aboard the Justice League
Watchtower Superman finally realizes
that enough is enough
he is sacrificed too much joined by
Wonder Woman in Shazam he questions the
higher-ups unfortunately for the group
Lex Luthor and Brainiac are aware of the
meeting holding the bottle city of
Kandor is a ransoming chickety of
threatened the Superfriends
they want to know who is free the heroes
and no Superman is the only one who can
obtain the answers
knowing that Batman's behind it
swoops down to the cave thinking he's a
legend thinking it's gonna be an easy
fight doing a Conor McGregor in a repeat
of last time he gets the absolute crap
kicked out of them it's absolutely
glorious hitting him from every angle
the Blue Boy Scout gets completely
pummeled
it's an earth-shattering moment watching
the flash bizarro
the robot dinosaure green arrow everyone
just taken the Man of Steel apart bit by
bit and when Batman arrives with his
kryptonite glove hammering him with
deadly shot after deadly shot it's a
triumphant moment and one of the
standout pieces of every Batman comic
ever combined I've seen many criticized
the drawn-out nature of Batman's return
but the fact that this entire comic
builds up to his entrance makes it that
much more impactful when he does show up
Frank Miller plays the wild card and it
pays off in my opinion but left with
Superman completely broken and Batman is
just saying I'm done playing the war is
on due to the art style the opening
issue really suffers and it struggles to
be as groundbreaking as it could have
been plot points lack their impact due
to the child like cartoonish nature of
the work which is a shame because it's
actually a lot here that deserves your
attention introducing Batman perfectly
this story feels more like a prologue to
the events that are to follow it
establishes elements of the world and
once it feels slightly unfocused you two
looking more like a Carrie Kelly story
than a Bruce Wayne one your enjoyment of
this issue really just depends on your
preferences if you like of a story or if
you want to read a Batman story with
Batman in it but to me the payoff at the
end of it is actually quite worth it
though it is an arduous journey it just
have comedic moments within but I can't
see it's still putting many people off
this may be the reason for its dire
reputation because it just fails to live
up to its predecessor
however I think there's a lot to enjoy
in this opening issue and it's so bad
it's good it's it's that kind of thing
and that's why overall I'm giving it a 7
point 5 out of 10 so what did you think
in the booth
comment below and let me know I'm gonna
be doing the entire Dark Knight strikes
again series into my build up of the
Dark Knight 3 the master race review so
make sure you subscribe my channel and
check out all that also check out my
website at definition code at UK because
I'm reading and reviewing all of the
Batman Canon graphic novels in
chronological order and it's been a
really good thing that's reading through
them all so I hope to see you there take
care peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]